en los corredores de bruselas la idea de
un salario mínimo europeo ha sido y
sigue siendo la manzana de la discordia
pero ahora francia quiere sacar adelante
la iniciativa hay grandes diferencias
salariales dentro del bloque europeo el
salario mínimo es de 332 euros en
bulgaria en francia es casi 5 veces más
mientras que luxemburgo encabeza la
clasificación con 2200 euros al mes una
cosa está clara fijar el mismo salario
mínimo en todos los estados miembros no
está sobre la mesa
no podemos declarar mañana ni en tres
años que el salario mínimo es el mismo
en toda europa económica e incluso
socialmente hablando es imposible pero
sí que es necesario que las cifras
aumenten hay dos bandos en contra de la
subida de los salarios más bajos por un
lado los seis países miembros donde no
hay un salario mínimo legal en estos
países las condiciones salariales se
acuerdan entre empresas y sindicatos los
países ricos del norte argumentan que en
su caso las directivas europeas podrían
llevar a una bajada de los sueldos por
otro lado
bulgaria y rumanía donde el salario
mínimo es inferior a los 500 euros no
quieren que los salarios aumenten
demasiado rápido algunos países juegan
con los salarios bajos para mantener su
competitividad así que es difícil pedir
a los negocios que aumenten los sueldos
de repente un 30 40 o 50 por ciento o
incluso más para alinearse con el resto
de la unión europea
por ahora la opinión más popular es que
el salario mínimo debería situarse en el
60 por ciento del salario medio de cada
estado la idea es que todo el mundo
pueda llegar a fin de mes sin embargo
las distintas oposiciones pueden
conllevar que el acuerdo final sea poco
ambicioso